when will my reflection show Who I am
inside my name is joy tawny I've been a
professional body painter for two and a
half years and a professional artist for
six hey guys I'm Jade today I'm gonna
paint Clarke and I suck at painting but
I get to pay my buddy today so let's do
this [ __ ] my name is Clarke and today I
will be the canvas let's get painting
so diminish they him since they're doing
it I can't wait to say normally this is
the part where I talk [ __ ] but I know
Joy's gonna kick my ass
how are you painting let's do this let's
do this let's go this is fine Clark
I never thought I'd have so much fun
pain in your belly I don't know where
Sponge Bob wears long sleeves or not
actually wears a shirt he doesn't have
spots and wait closing in on full
coverage now and then we'll get to do
you render your details yeah same here
[Music]
put in paint brushes and paint then on
Clark's body this night has given me
Picasso my work has Noah has no meaning
it can't be boxed you look like like a
techno Merman I've always loved the
colors of like Sailor Moon which is like
light blue and pink and yellow
Sailor Moon meets shape of water or a
person I wonder a face idea will still
recognize my face
five minutes I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to complete my masterpiece but
I'm gonna try really really hard
thinking about changing directions but
I'm totally a pro so change directions
like seven times Jay whoa whoa I think
this is when you start moving really
really fast so yep and I have to move
not at all
[Music]
ah a really nice skin thank you I'm
moisturize morning and night brush drop
my prey whoa oh my god
I like it wow so you're basically a
space mermaid I want to thank you from
this planet
so I gonna have to make the tough choice
and say that I think the overall winner
is joy the space fish and you did a
great job for your first time like it's
it's always difficult and especially
difficult to have your first time
happened on camera man I freaking sunk I
was not prepared I was just like Clark
pink body boom so I definitely
understand now that body painting is not
as easy as it looks so I actually really
originally came in here with the idea of
painting and Tiger which is why there's
a lot of stripes and then he was like oh
yeah it's themed under the sea and I'm
like damn ain't no type of Embassy